the owner of his place is a client
that's why we could get a table so
last-minute that's why they gave us this
bigger table
I imagine we'll send some complimentary
stuff to $55 for a steak known for their
meat here and $35 for a salmon get the
salmon to blow you for that price
[Music]
Harold Meyerowitz a son Matthew
yes mrs. Danny also fell tomorrow it's
his son I didn't realize he had two sons
and a daughter
be ok here it'll be nice to spend time
with DEP no I didn't get a lot of time
with him going up
[Music]
is posture in Italy they take all of the
little birds and deep-fry them and just
pump pump it's very sad
there are no little birds that in Italy
anymore
are going to meet a lot of interesting
people that didn't make it a month ago
it's because I like drugs so much
we're Harold meyerwitz you're on the
list for the public viewing right now
this is a private meeting others in the
state hello this is [ __ ]
yeah here's everything you're saying
[Music]
[Music]
I don't think I've ever seen gene run
yeah that's how she runs
[Music]
worried
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you